Thought you knew all there was to know about
Avengers: Endgame?
Think again.
A few eagle-eyed Marvel aficionados have spotted
an intriguing Easter egg tucked in the super-sized
superhero film.
Taking to the site's r/MovieDetails forum,
one Reddit user uploaded a screenshot of an
Avengers: Endgame scene that shows what seems
to be a travel log of all the time periods
the Avengers jumped in to in the film.
The log appears when the 2014 version of Nebula
is executing her plan to activate the time-travel
machine at Avengers HQ to bring Thanos to
the present day in 2023.
In the top right section of the screen, one
can spot the supposed user history, which
details in part that Earth's Mightiest Heroes
first traveled to May 2012, aka the setting
of the first Avengers movie.
Viewers saw this play out during the time
heist mission in Avengers: Endgame, but what
they didn't see is some of the heroes apparently
traveling to January 2988, a date which is
mysteriously included as the next entry in
the time-travel log.
Even weirder, it looks like the date specifically
says "2988 BC."
But that's not all.
A mention of the year 2988 can also be seen
in a different sequence in Avengers: Endgame.
When Chris Hemsworth's Thor is recapping the
events of Thor: The Dark World and describing
the nature of the Aether, aka the Reality
Stone, he shares a story about his grandfather
King Bor, an Asgardian who seized the Aether
from the Dark Elves thousands of years ago.
"My grandfather, many years ago, had to hide
the stone from the Dark Elves… oOoOoOh…
scary beings…”
Behind Thor, one of the screens reads "2988
B.C.", which may well be the same year that
Bor battled against the Dark Elf forces and
Malekith the Accursed to obtain the Aether.
"Millennia ago, the most ruthless of their
kind, Malekith, sought to transform our universe
back into one of eternal night."
In the version of Avengers: Endgame we all
saw, Thor and Rocket travel to Asgard in 2013,
intersecting with the events of Thor: The
Dark World.
They then proceed to obtain the Aether by
extracting it from Jane Foster.
However, the screen displaying the year 2988
B.C. hints that Thor and Rocket may have at
least discussed traveling back to the First
Battle of Svartalfheim instead, snatching
up the Aether way, way back in the past, instead
of just 2013.
There are some reasons why this might have
been an option for the team.
Thor clearly had mixed feelings about returning
to Asgard in the state we see him in in Endgame
depressed, anxious, overweight, and beating
himself up over his perceived mistakes he
made during the battle with Thanos.
Plus, he knew it would be painful to see his
homeland in the moments before thousands of
people were killed.
Not that jumping back to the bloody First
Battle of Svartalfheim would be any less intense
for Thor, but there would be at least a little
bit of emotional distance given how long ago
the battle took place.
It seems pretty plausible that some potential
cut or draft of Avengers: Endgame saw the
heroes leaping back to the year 2988 B.C.,
before it was decided to loop in the more
modern-day events of Thor: The Dark World
instead.
As far as we can tell, the filmmakers haven't
talked about this, so we really don't know.
"I have no idea, we're talking about time
travel here."
Some people think the out-of-place date has
nothing to do with the plot of the movie,
and is instead a reference to an alternate
Earth from Marvel's "What If" Comics: Earth-2988.
In that reality, Wolverine became a horseman
of the powerful villain Apocalypse.
Some see the number as possibly being a clue
for how the X-Men will join the MCU, but that
seems like a stretch.
But it's just as likely that some version
of the movie saw Thor and Rocket taking an
alternate route to get the Aether, and not
all of the computer graphics in the final
movie got the message but that's just speculation.
We may never unravel the full mystery of this
strange time travel detail.
Either way, it goes to show that there's a
lot more going on in this three-hour movie
then anyone at first realized.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.